moi je suis ici puisque déjà je suis
très stressée un faut être honnête
puisque je suis étudiant je voulais tout
vous j'ai beaucoup plus simple
être à votre place qu'à la mienne un
clairement puisque pas plus tard qu'hier
j'étais sur les bancs de l'école à
travailler la communication
alors je suis local de l'étape puisque
j'habite armand voilà je suis roiné est
déjà pas mal
à côté de l'école j'ai fait pas mal de
choses et c'est pour ça que je suis je
suis ici devant vous cet après midi et
on va parler de quelque chose qui
aggravent qui a conduit ma vie c'est
comme en gravir des montagnes et je vais
vous expliquer comment on va faire et
comment j'ai fait qu'elle mindset j'ai
eu pour gravir des montagnes alors une
montagne autant vous dire que j'ai pas
gravi l'everest
j'ai pas la compétence physique pour y
aller un clairement mais par contre j'ai
gravi mont everest et mont everest c'est
mes objectifs professionnels notamment
donc on va essayer de les définir voir
ce que j'ai ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
essayé de faire très objectif je me suis
fixé et ce qui a fait que ça a peu
avancé
donc comment de ravir des montagnes ça
commence déjà par savoir ce qu'on veut
faire puisque moi je viens de nulle part
mes parents sont infirmières et agents
sncf
rien à voir avec l'entrepreneuriat pas
du tout ni la politique je suis parti de
rien mais j'avais une passion à 14 13 14
ans c'était l'événementiel jeu qui fait
graver faire du spectacle surtout les
regarde et on pouvait pas faire grand
chose
je voulais faire du spectacle et j'ai
été beaucoup inspirés notamment par un
producteur parisien qui a produit gad
elmaleh notamment et cette personne là
m'a beaucoup inspiré j'ai vu beaucoup de
spectacles qu'il a produit et notamment
il m'a emmené au plus grand cabaret du
monde
or c'est peut-être pas grand-chose si ce
qui ça n'existe plus maintenant mais
c'était et c'est une émission sur france
2 et j'ai adoré ça et ça m'a donné
vraiment envie de produire des artistes
et pauvres pour ce faire on ne peut pas
devenir producteur d'un seul coup il
faut faire des premiers pas et ce
premier pas là je vais vous l'expliquer
après je les fais très rapidement
ensuite vous avez aussi mon grand père
mon appel était chef d'entreprise dans
les prés c'est tout quelque chose au
complètement spéciale de l'industrie il
était chef d'entreprise et ça m'a donné
aussi envie de faire deux
reprenant arrière et aussi il était
premier adjoint dans ma ville et c'est
ce qui m'a aussi montrer la voie vers ça
qui est l engagement citoyen pour pour
mes concitoyens et vous allez tous à
vous avez l'entrepreneuriat vous avez
l'événementiel vous avez la politique
etc c'est un petit florilège de choses
qui a fait que j'ai voulu me lancer là
dedans alors tout toute expédition vers
un sommet de montagne ça commence par
les exemples donc que je vous ai cités d
inspiration et aussi faire des premiers
pas et c'est pour ça qu'on est là
aujourd'hui on m'a demandé
thomas a fait une conférence sur le
premier pas ne pas se mettre de
barrières ce que j'ai 21 ans mais je me
suis pas mis de barrière et c'est ce qui
a fait que je suis là à faire ses
premiers pas c'est avant tout tester et
ne pas avoir peur de tester alors que
très jeune pour ma carrière entre
guillemets politique
j'ai commencé par me présenter au
conseil départemental citoyen je sais
pas si on a qui l'ont fait étant jeune
mais c'est quelque chose on fait une
campagne dans son collège et on est élu
pour deux ans et avec ça j'ai fait des
actions au profit des personnes
handicapées via le sport de l'inclusion
comme ça c'était mon premier pas dans
l'engagement citoyen après vous l'avez
sûrement tous déjà fait quand vous étiez
jeune quand vous étiez jeune vers 13 14
ans j'ai commencé à acheter les
premières lumières gifi je pense que
vous connaissez ces petites soirées un
pot pourri qu'on a fait quand on était
jeune eh ben j'ai commencé comme ça j'ai
fait une première soirée que les
lumières de chez gifi une 1 112 sur le
côté et j'ai fait partir mais première
soirée alors c'était souvent pour des
amis de la famille ça s'arrêtait là mais
ça fonctionnait bien et est en fait
c'était un peu mon i qui gagne c'est à
dire que c'était forcément un premier
pas mais ça plaisait aux gens les gens
en avaient besoin
il était content j'étais plutôt bon
dedans et sur tout le monde paye et on
me payait très jeune pour faire des
soirées
donc j'ai commencé comme ça avec ce
premier pas là j'ai fait tout à fait une
carrière scolaire comme les autres
puisque je suis encore étudiant
mais j'ai fait un bac s tout simplement
et après
gg j'ai eu la chance d'intégrer une
école de communication qui est lisse
comme et c'était mon coup la chose qui
m'a permis d'avoir des outils avant ça
vous avez les objectifs à vous fixer
il faut les définir très tôt et en les
définissant il faut les acheteurs mais
aussi si vous les affirme époque vous
allez avoir du mal à les entendre
quand je dis affirmé alors là c'est les
premiers moments vous allez avoir de la
concurrence des gens qui vont essayer de
vous rabaisser
c'est ici c'est quand vous avez commencé
à afficher vos ambitions
mais c'est normal et ce surtout bon
signe si vous commencez à définir vos
objectifs il faut pas avoir de complexes
c'est à dire si mademoiselle où elle est
présidente de la république c'est
possible voilà mais par contre il faudra
faire des étapes entre et c'est pour ça
que j'ai mis pas à pas fixez vous des
objectifs au si vous les connaissez
avec des exemples que vous avez eue mais
surtout donnez vous des points de
repères et des petites cahutes sur la
montagne qui vont permettre de gravir de
s'arrêter de profiter prendre un peu de
souffle de récompenser et à près de
monter encore et c'est comme ça que vous
allez réussir à aller plus haut donc
j'ai commencé avec les petites lumières
de gifi et puis après ça fonctionnait
correctement et à 18 ans et un jour j'ai
créé la société
j'ai commencé j'avais un petit peu de
matériel pas plus que ça et pendant deux
ans tout l'argent que je récupérer via
l'entreprise
vous repartez en investissement donc
tout le bénéfice sur deux ans tout
reparte et dont il faut s'engager il
faut pas avoir peur de mettre son temps
et son argent là dedans il faut pas non
plus vous pourriez me dire oui mais à 18
ans tu aurais pu arrêter complètement
tes études
c'était possible mais j'ai pas voulu
puisque les études c'est bien aussi
ça permet d'apprendre et d'avoir les
outils et il ya une phrase que moi
j'aime tout particulièrement et que vous
allez peut-être avoir aequo avec ça avec
votre carrière
mais faire avant de faire faire c'est
quelque chose qui m'a guidé réellement
avant de produire des artistes faut déjà
savoir un petit peu ce que c'est d'être
artiste
donc il faut l'être avant de rendre les
dj j'ai fait dj avant de rendre des
photographes
j'ai fait photographe ainsi de suite
c'est tout le temps la même chose
vous ne pouvez pas demander à des gens
enfin vous pouvez mais c'est compliqué
de faire quelque chose que vous n'avez
aucune notion si vous voulez faire un
site internet
même si vous ne savez pas le faire
essayez quand même d'avoir les bases
pour après savoir diriger celui qui est
celui qui le fera réellement en fait il
faut savoir faire les choses et après
délégué c'est important
délégué aux personnes qui savent mieux
le faire que vous et ça c'est une phrase
qui est super importante voilà apprendre
travailler ses compétences et surtout
faire voilà avant de commencer à
déléguer et ne plus rien faire
j'aime bien j'aime bien parler cette
phrase assez gravir l'everest ont
caquette chaussettes c'est compliqué
pourquoi c'est compliqué si vous pouvez
arrêter vos études ou de à la troisième
c'est possible vous pouvez faire des
super truc mais forcément si vous voulez
vous gravir l'everest
ça sera forcément plus compliqué en
claquettes chaussettes forcément mais
vous vous avez la chance d'avoir tous un
superbe voyage des moonboots tout ce
qu'il faut pour gravir l'everest
s'engager et s'investir dans son projet
c'est total totalement et c'est aussi
votre temps
c'est 100 % c'est à dire que pendant mes
années d'études à l'école alice comme la
semaine j'étais en cours le samedi je
faisais des soirées et le dimanche je
faisais du drone genre je reviendrai à
ça et la nuit jeu développé un site
internet puisque je travaillais mais à
côté de ça j'avais une vision un projet
pour l'événementiel qui était du belize
et la profession et c'est pour moi
quelque chose qui ne s'était pas encore
fait et qu'il fallait faire donc je me
suis investi dans un marché qui existait
déjà
c'est ça aussi la force entreprendre
dans un milieu où le marché existe déjà
c'est que vous savez que vous aurez des
clients et c'est super important si vous
lancez votre start-up attention à pas
essayer de le rentrer dans un marché qui
est compliqué enfin qui existent pas
vous pouvez vous casser la gueule mais
ça peut fonctionner ça c'est sûr et c
est cette chose là cet objectif ne peut
pas se faire tout seul c'est pas
possible
donc il faut avoir des équipes et
surtout des clients
c'est aussi important et forcément j'ai
eu beaucoup de mal au début
un ou deux vous devez vous en douter à
18 19 ans à aller voir eiffage ou
responsable commercial de renault et lui
dire je vais
votre gala 30000 euros ce n'était pas
simple mais à force de prendre de
conviction et de persuasion
on y arrive c'est possible faut pas se
mettre de vrais radio oui j'ai 19 ans
c'est pas possible ils vont pas me faire
confiance
non faut pas se dire sa foi se dire que
déjà première chose c'est que c'est la
personne qui a besoin de vous et pas
l'inversé quand vous allez chez mcdo
vous avez besoin de mc do si vous
entreprenez c'est les autres ont besoin
de vous et c'est comme ça que vous allez
réussir à convaincre d'une part combien
de vos clients qui vont permettre de
payer votre équipe mais ça marche aussi
pour votre équipe
vers surtout quand on est jeune fille
voulait fédérer pour créer votre start
up c'est mieux de convaincre et serrer
son équipe
donc allez-y n'ayez pas peur seul on va
plus vite ensemble on va plus loin c'est
bien connu
développer innover ajusté c'était un peu
moins mon fil rouge c'est à dire que oui
je travaille et je faisais des galas les
dj tu as vu le truc un peu de base
étages au départ mais on a essayé avec
mon équipe d'innover et comme je vous ai
dit déconstruire un petit peu l'idée
qu'on se fait de l'événementiel venir un
site internet
donc c'est comme ça que ça nous a fait
grandir et lui l'opic que vous avez
votre objectif qui est le sommet de la
montagne
vous n'avez pas qu'une seule possibilité
d'y monter vous pouvez monter
différentes façons et vous pouvez y
monte déjà vous pouvez prendre votre
temps est forcément si vous connaissez
plus jeunes c'est plus simple quand vous
avez 80 ans monter l'everest c'est plus
compliqué que quand vous en avez 20 mai
c'est pas impossible
c'est pas impossible et vous avez deux
manières d'y arriver au niveau de
montagne vous pouvez y aller à pied et
vous serez légitime quand vous y serez
en eau soit vous y allez en hélicoptère
vous fait prêter de l'argent vous montez
votre entreprise vous êtes directement
chefs d'entreprise mais vous n'avez pas
forcément cette les jt légitimité là
pardon et ses skis et c'est ce qui est
important c'est pour moi entreprendre
c'est aussi bien sûr sont elles pas ne
pas se mettre derrière et faire le
premier pas c'est plus compliqué les
trois premières années quand j'ai
commencé c'était les plus compliquées
quand je disais on va on va créer une
société on va travailler pour des
grosses boîtes on va faire un show son
et lumière pour le rugby à rouen pour le
foot à roye aussi non mais c'est pas
possible tu as 19 ans
de déconner il y en a ils sont là depuis
30 ans dans le métier voilà j'y ai cru
et au final on l'a fait et en se fixant
des petits objectifs c'est-à-dire moi
j'avais un petit truc ça peut paraître
banal mais je voulais je suis fan de
foot et je voulais absolument pour me
féliciter d'avoir un petit panneau un
petit panneau led avec le nom de la
société sur un bord du terrain
ça peut paraître anodin mais vous fixez
vous des petits objectifs comme ça même
si c'est des bêtises vous les avez et
vous vous y allez quand vous les
formaliser
quand vous les dites à vos parents à vos
profs à vos collègues
déjà rien que le fait de le dire ça vous
donner envie d'y aller si vous le dites
pas ça va rester au fond de vous et vous
avez eu un bon je vais je vais y aller
non j'y vais pas et c'est donc si vous
le dis toi je veux créer mon entreprise
tout le monde va dire ouais il va créer
son entreprise et là vous êtes obligé
d'y aller
donc c'est comme ça que le maïs est doit
se doit se faire et aussi dernière chose
se diversifier alors vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que le l'événementiel c'est
un peu la merde en ce moment un
clairement je ne travaille plus voilà je
suis en chômage clairement mais il a
fallu que je me diversifie et ça s'est
passé avec le passage d'un brevet télé
pilotes de drones au spice et c'est
quelque chose de complètement
anecdotique mais ça a permis sur les six
derniers mois de sauver un peu
l'entreprise est est ce que est ce que
j'y faisais donc ça permet de se
sécuriser
j'ai mis entre parenthèses ligne de vie
j'aime bien parler de ça c'est à dire
que vous avez plusieurs lignes de vie
vous avez les études c'est une ligne de
vie quand vous montez votre adresse vous
avez le mousqueton et vous avez votre
ligne de vie et moi ce que je conseille
c'est d'en avoir plusieurs des lignes de
vie même si ça même si elles sont pas
solides au moins ils sont là alors que
la première ligne de vie pour moi c'est
l'entreprise
après vous allez pilotage de drones
après vous avez mon engagement pour ma
ville après vous avez les études c'est
un parachute mais toutes ces lignes la
permettent
elles sont elles ne sont pas dépendantes
mais elles ont une synergie entre elles
si j'avais pas été entrepreneur
peut-être que je n'aurais pas été
conseiller municipal puisque le maire
n'aurait peut-être pas eu mon profil
entre les mains
et être entrepreneur c'est bien plus
simple quand vous êtes dans le monde de
l'engagement politique ça vous permet de
rencontrer du monde etc
vous avez des synergies comme ça qui
permet d'avancer plus vite et plus
fortement est une belle inertie donc
vous vous avez toutes les cartes en main
pour y arriver on est au même endroit on
a tous j'ai 21 ans
donc voyez on assure je suis plus jeune
que mais vous avez toutes les cartes en
main vous avez tous le le piolet vous
avez les bonnes chaussures et surtout
z'avez l'otan vous pouvez prendre des
risques donc prenez les et et partez
partez
prenez vos jambes fait le premier pas
n'ayez pas peur du regard des autres
puisque le regard des jeux d'autres il
changera au furet bout au fur et à
mesure des haines merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]